bonsoir nous vous emmenons ce soir dans
les pas de la grande mademoiselle et
dans ce qui fut sa demeure des deals le
château de saint fargeau aujourd'hui un
château de 150 pièces 55 ruminer un parc
de 120 hectares la visite est un pur
moment d'émerveillement avec depuis l'an
dernier
un brin de magie supplémentaire le jeudi
2 les prix jusqu'au 28 août vous voilà
replonger dans l'ambiance des toques par
la grâce d'une visite de nuit aux
chambres il est 22 heures la cour du
château s'anime en douceur sous le
regard de personnages amis ville le
public fait son entrée ce jeudi-là 300
personnes se sont déplacées pour une
plongée dans le passé
au son de la cloche les groupes déjà
constitués rejoignent leur dit non
nous suivrons amis qui retrace en
quelques minutes histoire du château
dont les origines remontent au 10ème
siècle
mickey vraiment été transformé par la
volonté d'antoine de chabannes c'était
top 14
153 dont le château actuel est construit
sur les bases du château fort pour qu'il
avait déjà 700 très particulière
pentagone irrégulier nous avons 5 l et
si tout
gris le groupe entre dans la bâtisse à
la seule lueur des bougies
vous l'aviez peut-être de créer des
traits un peu plus intime voire sa fin
je faisais un autre angle la nôtre avec
d'autres lumières et on n'avait pas
encore fait visiter saint fargeau de
nuit avec ses ambiances là on avait le
spectacle les qui réunit déjà d'autres
effectifs et caves un autre endroit dans
le parc à l'extérieur et si c'est vrai
que c'est plus intime et avec la lueur
des bougies ou rendre dans un cadre
magique nous plonge tout de suite dans
cette époque là où du fait tiennent au
xviiie siècle un jour je voulais donc à
la nuire des pions de l'ict les vicaires
s'imprègne de la vie à saint fargeau du
temps de la grande mademoiselle cousine
de louis xiv il est ici pour avoir
participé à la fraude
dans chaque pièce une saynète dans la
salle à manger
l'entrée du petit marmiton animent la
scène la légende veut que ce soit lui
lit enfant compositeur d'une célèbre
chanson les spectateurs deviennent
acteurs jouent avec les personnages à
colin-maillard ou à la chaise musicale
ce qui rend plus compliquée et c'est la
visibilité parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
des endroits aussi un petit peu sombre
et là on a fait en sorte que les choses
soient plus faciles les marges sont là
diminue donc demain pas qui est des
chutes après gérer un groupe de
personnes qui d'un regard de temps
pourtant sont absorbés par d'autres
choses et bien qu'il faut ramener parce
qu'on fait précisément le télé qu'il
célèbre propriétaire du château xviiie
siècle à la révolution il fut le premier
à renoncer à ses droits seigneuriaux
puis a voté la mort du roi
ce qui n'empêchait pas la bonne société
de l'époque de sa musique en s'adonnant
par exemple contrepèterie un détour par
les cuisines pour déguster quelques
gâteaux le château n'a plus de secret
les surprises mythique les visiteurs
apprennent l'histoire en salle à manger
pas plus que je peux y le temps
d'apprendre avant
et c'est sur le perron du château que la
visite s'achève le public visiblement
compris à l'image de cette famille de
touristes denis de suisse c'est vraiment
formidable tout est bien pensé sur sa
formidable côté des dossiers qu'on voit
pas chez nous et qui manque peut-être
effectivement mais c'est fantastique
c'est vraiment savoureux manifeste en
pense quoi
monsanto certains voient pas souvent en
suisse
ces visites de nuit remporté un réel
succès pour les jeudis du mois d'août
il vous est donc très vivement
recommandé de réserver